the hot new invite divorce parties oh
that doesn't make sense I wanted to
celebrate not a divorce but a new
chapter with people whom I love who want
the best for me says sellers who works
at a cloud computing company in Columbus
Ohio divorce used to be something to be
ashamed of due to societal pressures and
stereotypes says Nicole sedoma a divorce
lawyer who wrote the book please don't
say you're sorry about the topic but
today people have really decided to nip
that societal shame and instead Embrace
being divorced as another stage of life
that some of us experience but yeah
divorce is just another stage of Life uh
says the divorce lawyer kind of like you
know totaling your car at the bottom of
a ravine
[Music]
it's just another stage of driving home
from work